are there some other easy ways that
people can add humor into conversation
in terms of more spontaneous
conversational stuff there's a lot of
different types of humor Russell Brand
is very fast clever callback witty
that's tougher to implement an easy one
is to say the opposite and it sounds
dumb but if it's a super hot day and
everyone's about how hot it is and you
go out you're like man it's cold
out here I swear to God you will get a
chuckle from people the other thing that
I recommend people do is you can prime
yourself so rather than thinking of
humor if I think how I did it it wasn't
by purposely working in saying the
opposite necessarily it was by watching
a lot of Chris Pratt before I would go
out and put myself in that mode of
ridiculous non-sequitur statement and
just lift these lines straight out of
movies into context that it didn't make
any sense and that actually worked
really well so yeah just watching them
for 10-15 minutes before going into a
social interaction was actually the way
that I did